what's going on guys this is rob and you
may have heard
that zach schneider's justice league is
coming to hbo max on march 18th and if
you're not someone who closely follows
the behind-the-scenes happening of the
dc extended universe you may have
thought to yourself didn't that movie
come out like three years ago and yes
yes it did but this time it's different
supposedly you see the film we saw
released in 2017
represented only half of zack snyder's
original vision for the film but to
fully understand what's going on here we
need to first explain the dc extended
universe now unless you've been living
under a rock
for the past decade and some change
there's no doubt that you're familiar
with the marvel cinematic universe the
best highest grossing film franchise in
history whose 23 films have grossed over
22 billion dollars worldwide well
naturally warner brothers saw how much
success disney was having with their
superhero movies and thought hey we own
the rights to some superheroes let's
produce movies featuring those
characters we won't put in as much
effort but will be just as successful
and so that's what they set out to do so
warner brothers decided that the
foundation of this franchise would be a
solo film about their most well-known
character
superman and this is a completely
logical move for them after all if the
marvel cinematic universe could be built
on the foundation of a movie about iron
man who at the time
was an incredibly obscure character
outside of comic book fandom then using
the most recognizable superhero on the
planet to launch a franchise
should be super easy to do so in 2019
man of steel premiered directed by zack
snyder who'd had some success with comic
book adaptations prior to taking the
helm of man of steel with 2006's 300 and
2009's watchmen
and this movie proved to be pretty
divisive among critics with a fairly
middle of the road rating of 56
on rotten tomatoes with the main
criticism being that it focused mostly
on big time fights and action scenes
without really doing much character
development
or telling a compelling story and to a
degree it kind of makes sense zack
snyder's just a mini michael bay and
although the fan reaction was mostly
positive some long time superman fans
were put off by the darker grittier tone
of the film compared to past superman
movies as they felt it didn't fit the
character now while we've all gotten
used to seeing a dark gritty batman
and christopher nolan's trilogy of
batman films were very successful and
well received this particular tone
doesn't really fit superman who's used
as a symbol of hope instead of
instilling fear in his enemies like
batman does now man of steel would end
up grossing
668 million dollars worldwide which was
successful enough that warner brothers
felt comfortable using it to launch
their connected film universe so they
decided to make a sequel to the man of
steel with henry cavill reprising his
role as superman and for this sequel
they decided you know what we're putting
batman
in this movie and i think this was
really a screw-up on warner brothers
part because while i understand that
everyone knows who batman is so you
don't necessarily need an origin story
this whole thing felt rushed what made
the marvel movies so successful was the
shared universe that all their heroes
inhabited and that's why avengers was
the biggest movie of all time when it
came out in 2012 because
fans wanted to see these heroes share
the screen but what marvel did
prior to the avengers was establish all
of the heroes in their own solo movies
we didn't get iron man and then the
avengers instead we got thor
and we got hulk and we got captain
america they all got their own movies
and iron man even got a second solo
movie before they were all thrown
together and so instead of copying this
ultra successful blueprint dc
decided to go the wrong way and when i
say dc i technically mean warner
brothers dc's parent company but you
guys know what i mean so in 2016
zack snyder's second film in the dc
extended universe batman vs superman
dawn of justice premiered henry cavill
reprised his role as superman
and a new batman was introduced played
by ben affleck who i thought was a great
batman and the primary motive for this
movie as his name implies is to set up a
justice league movie as an
answer to marvel's avengers according to
critics the movie suffered from many of
the same problems at his predecessor
relying too heavily
on special affection action scenes at
the expense of story and character
development
and they really just panned it i mean to
the tune of a 26
rating on rotten tomatoes and this movie
was really asked to do a lot of work in
addition to introducing batman the film
also introduced two major villains lex
luthor and doomsday and just for good
measure
introduced wonder woman as well so you
can imagine this movie was pretty long
two and a half hours but even so this is
just a lot to cram into a single film
now once again
a lot of viewers were put off by the
overly serious tone of the movie and
didn't like that it was basically devoid
of humor which had been something fans
had come to expect in superhero films
due to the popularity of the marvel
movies but still the film made 873
million dollars worldwide and dc plowed
ahead building towards the justice
league film
and this is where we can finally get
into explaining what the snyder cut is
so zack snyder is back directing the
justice league film which will see
superman batman and wonder woman return
and introduce even more heroes namely
aquaman the flash and cyborg but getting
this movie to the big screen
was a difficult process not only had
snyder's previous outing batman vs
superman
been poorly received but the next
installment in the dceu
suicide squad didn't perform so hot
either and so snyder had co-written a
script with screenwriter chris terrio
which according to snyder was really
ambitious and featured darkseid one of
dc's most popular villains but this
version of the movie
never got made instead snyder ontario
began rewriting the script to have a
more hopeful tone and brighter color
palette to aid in this process
warner brought in acclaimed comic book
writer jeff johns to help with the
script rewrites and ben affleck was also
part of the writing process so the
justice league would flow seamlessly
into the batman movie which he was
supposed to direct and star in the
result was a much less ambitious
and pared-down script now despite a
bunch of rewrites justice league got
filmed but during the post-production
zack snyder left the film and so warner
decided to bring in joss whedon who you
guys might know as the director of the
avengers among other things to basically
finish this film now after whedon was
brought in it was announced there would
be reshoots of certain parts of the film
and when the film was released in
theaters it was substantially different
than the version slider had created when
he left the project now according to
schneider he hasn't seen the theatrical
release of justice league but he says
that based on what he's been told about
it they only used about 25 percent of
his material
others who worked on the movie have said
however that around 80 of snyder's film
made it into the theatrical release but
that seems unlikely since snyder's cut
of the film is four hours long and the
run time of the theatrical release was
only two hours and so at any rate the
film was not a commercial success
grossing 658 million dollars at the box
office substantially less than batman vs
superman and critics generally met it
with negative reviews as well that
includes me so at this point
dc kind of gave up on the extended
universe assuming they even tried in the
first place the ben affleck batman movie
never really happened nor did the
planned sequel to the justice league
they kept wonder woman and aquaman and
their solo movies were generally met
with more enthusiasm by both fans and
critics than any of the other snyder dc
movies had been which makes sense
because wonder woman and aquaman were
amazing but there was a significant
contingent of fans that blamed justice
league's failure on joss whedon claiming
that his reshoots had ruined the movie
snyder had planned now i don't really
know what led them to believe this
since none of them actually knew what
was in the snyder cut or knew with any
certainty that the snyder cut even
existed at that point but they really
believed it with a passion maybe they
were just legitimately huge fans of
snyder's signature dark and gritty style
or maybe they were just hardcore dc fans
that were desperate for the dc movies to
be as good as the marvel movies so they
just chose to believe that this unseen
film was a masterpiece
instead of facing the undeniable truth
that the marvel movies are far superior
who can say for sure
but anyway these fans started a petition
to release the snyder cut which got over
180 000 signatures and there were even
members of the movie's cast and crew
most notably jason mamoa who played
aquaman who advocated for the snyder cut
to be released as well
fans were so devoted to this cause that
they crowdfunded ad space in times
square to coincide with new york comic
con which is actually a pretty big
achievement so kudos to you guys
unfortunately with that passion came
some toxicity and while i'm sure most
snyder fans do not fall into that
category the movement did develop that
reputation
due to instances like the former
president of dc entertainment deleting
her twitter account
due to being harassed by snyder fans
something i'd like to point out here for
all the casual moviegoers out there
most of us as comic book fans are not
people like that like we're normal
people we have social skills and we have
common sense and we know how to express
our irritation and frustration without
taking to social media
and just lambasting you for having a
different opinion we are not those guys
so as for snyder himself he was
supportive of the movement and in 2019
he confirmed that his cut of the film
did in fact exist
putting the ball in the court of warner
brothers as to whether it would be
released or not later that year snyder
entered into discussions with warner
media to finish his version of justice
league for a release on the new hbo max
streaming service in 2021
and so snyder began working on the movie
but the production suffered some
complications due to the kovan 19
pandemic but in may 2020 snyder
announced that the film would indeed be
released
as zack snyder's justice league on hbo
max now finishing the movie
proved to be an expensive endeavor with
several of the film's actors including
henry cavill and ben affleck as well as
some of the actors that had not been in
the theatrical release coming in to
shoot additional scenes
according to snyder all this was done
for four to five minutes of new material
which
it seems like the juice wouldn't be
worth the squeeze here but i don't know
that's just me anyway in january of 2021
snyder announced that his version of the
film was complete and that instead of
being released in four one hour
installments as originally planned
they're going to release the entire four
long movie on hbo max on march 18th
so yeah that's the story of zack
snyder's justice league or the snyder
cut as people call it and i'm curious to
know you guys thoughts on it are you
excited that it's finally getting
released or does the fact that the dc
extended universe has largely been
abandoned dampen your excitement let me
know in the comments section with that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
to an end thank you guys for watching
and i will catch you all
later peace